[Music]  none of us really know each other but  somehow we were all in the same place at  the same time when Billy found those  coins for straw the same these try  the answer to what is happening to you  is here you five are the Power Rangers  did I just hear you say where Power  Rangers this I'm gonna joke we're  talking to a wall  I was kind of expecting a little more  our Rangers were a legion of warriors  you must become those warriors  it's the hologram like a video game it's  a strong-ass hologram a video he was  born for this I destroy everything  she is cure evil how do you expect us to  stop it  it's morphin time do it better than  anybody ever seen  there's a lot of gold this is your  destiny  this is your time  followed in job  guys check out how we glow I'm blue oh  I'm black what I hear no no you're not